We're going to...
To see the unveiling of the pole
of the Pole Marker.
It's a ceremony, so I dressed up
... and, uh...
It's a South Pole tradition.
Once a year.
Unveiling of the Marker
that was designed the previous year
by the Winterovers.
Let's go!
The story is, this is January 1st
... and, uh...
every year, we have to mark
the new location of the axis of rotation
because we're on this large sheet of ice
that moves by about 10 meters a year.
So, that's what we're doing today.
So this is the old marker.
It's old and dirty and
- It is time for a change.
Time for a change. Enough of this one.
And I guess the new one
is around here,
about to be unveiled.
Ready?
Whoaaaa!
Nice.
Is it Jupiter?
Yeah, it's like, it looks like Jupiter, 'cause of the bands
but
Saturn rings...
I don't really understand either.
But maybe it's not to be understood.
It's nice.
Actually, it's Saturn but it looks like Jupiter.
Yeah, 'cause there's bands,
so I'm not quite sure.
- Wait, is it supposed to be Saturn though?
So as of today
the Earth is actually turning around this point.
Hey everyone!
... Uh, what was I gonna say?
Yeah, I look a little tired because
I just came back from work, and it's 3 AM.
Can't you see, the sun is over there
that means it's 3 AM.
I just came here before going to sleep
to... to show you. This is the Ceremonial Pole right here.
This is the place that doesn't actually change where we have this nice aluminized, or metalized, globe
and then you see the flags of the countries
who I think have signed the Antarctic Treaty, I'm not quite sure.